first award for the category best
Technical and research project on a
competitive topic goes to uh Dr Uma
yadav who holds a PhD in life sciences
and her topic was on machine learning
approach for drug response prediction in
diffuse large B cell lymphoma patients I
would like to Congress you later uh Uma
are you here with us can you please
um unmute yourself and also turn on your
camera
yes
oh
yeah so uh can you hear me
yes I can help you congratulations so
yes thank you I would like to take this
opportunity to thank our mix logic find
bio for this platform this has been a
great platform and is a great platform
not only for graduate students but also
for continued learning and upgrading
your skills and knowledge which is the
need of time I'm grateful to my mentor
Dr rindran for his guidance I thank
sonalika for immense support throughout
the project thank you all at omic's
logic sparsh and SRI gory I thank all
the judges and I also congratulate all
the participants for their work thank
you all